wir haben durch das Urteil vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht im November
mussten wir jetzt eine fast 20
Milliarden Lücke für den aktuellen
Haushalt 2024 schließen das ist das was
da im Dezember stattgefunden hat mit all
seinen Auswirkungen fürs nächste
Haushaltsjahr 2025 wird diese Lücke
größer wahrscheinlich 25 Milliarden und
so weiter wenn nicht auf der einnahmeite
oder auf der Ausgabenseite irgendwas
grundsätzliches gemacht wird wenn jetzt
also Herr Lindner kommt ich nehme mal
ihn beispielhaft und sagt Soli
Abschaffung für Unternehmen in
Deutschland korrigieren Sie mich ich
glaube da reden wir über 7inhalb
Milliarden in etwa die das ausmachen
würde und er macht kein
gegenfinanzierungsvorschlag dazu wo das
herkommen soll dann heißt das nichts
anderes als die eh schon 25 Milliarden
große Lücke die wir schließen müssen für
den nächsten Haushalt 2025 wird einfach
noch mal um 7inhalb Milliarden größer da
muss man jetzt kein Bundesfinanzminister
sein um zu wissen das wird nicht
funktionieren